kicking off the summer with the new song
and then I'm finishing with summer with
the release of the album but luckily we
won't have to wait that long this
weekend Shania is headlining this year's
stagecoach Country Music Festival and
yes she is debuting her new song first
single is just it's so optimistic and
hopeful regardless of how bad life can
get and I really needed that message
music is my is my therapy it's my drugs
songwriting especially more than
anything in music because it if my
outlet my emotional outlet we all have
crap in our lives and but you know gee
music is such a great place to can you
know to commune and forget about our
worries together
and what better ways to put those
worries aside than joining the voice
judges for coaching duties mark is
adorable
it's got the technique I don't think
there's anything standing in his way
it's really more about performance at
the stage and if there was any inkling
that she wouldn't love every minute of
it how about a contestant singing her
huge hit man I feel like a woman
[Music]
and I what do you think I think it was
just awesome and a huge compliment to me
you really do have the fast it's been a
true team community spirit all the way
man she allowed a woman
[Music]